En este video hablaremos de las fuerzas
que existen incluso entre átomos neutros o
moléculas neutras. Para empezar con estas fuerzas
intermoleculares hablaremos de las fuerzas de
dispersión de London. Suena muy elegante, pero
en realidad es un fenómeno bastante interesante
y casi intuitivo. Estamos acostumbrados a pensar
en átomos. Digamos que tenemos 1 átomo neutro que
tiene el mismo número de protones y electrones.
Estos son todos los protones y neutrones en el
núcleo, y luego tendrá una nube de electrones.
Sólo estoy imaginando todos estos electrones
saltando alrededor. Lo voy a representar de esta
manera. Esto definitivamente no está dibujado a
escala, el núcleo en realidad sería mucho más
pequeño, pero digamos que hay un átomo decente
justo aquí. Y también es neutro, quizás el mismo
tipo de átomo, podría ser diferente pero vamos a
decir que es neutro, y también tiene una nube de
electrones. Y si ambos tienen carga neutra, ¿cómo
se atraerían entre sí? Y eso es lo que explican
las fuerzas de dispersión de London en realidad,
porque hemos observado que incluso los átomos
neutros y las moléculas neutras pueden atraerse
entre sí. Y la forma de pensar en esto es que
los electrones están constantemente saltando,
de manera probabilística están en esta nube de
densidad de probabilidad, donde 1 electrón podría
estar en cualquier lugar, en cualquier momento
dado, pero no siempre se distribuirán de manera
uniforme. Podemos imaginar que hay un momento en
el que el átomo de la izquierda podría verse así,
sólo por un momento, donde quizás la mayoría
de los electrones se encuentren en el lado
izquierdo del átomo más que en el lado derecho.
Tal vez se ve como algo así. Y durante ese momento
breve tienes una carga parcial negativa. Esta
es la letra griega delta [δ], delta minúscula,
que se usa para denotar carga parcial. Y de este
lado puede tener una carga parcial positiva,
porque recordemos que cuando estaba distribuida
uniformemente la carga negativa se compensaba
por la carga positiva del núcleo, pero aquí en el
lado derecho, debido a que hay menos electrones,
tal vez tenemos una carga parcial positiva. En
el lado izquierdo, donde están la mayoría de los
electrones en ese momento, tenemos carga parcial
negativa. Ahora, ¿qué podría inducir esto en el
átomo vecino? Piénsalo, pausa el video y piensa
¿qué podría pasar en el átomo vecino? Bueno,
sabemos que las cargas iguales se repelen y
cargas opuestas se atraen entre sí, de modo que
si tenemos una carga parcial positiva en el lado
derecho de este átomo izquierdo, bueno, entonces
los electrones negativos podrían ser atraídos por
este átomo de la derecha, así que estos electrones
en realidad podrían ser jalados un poco hacia la
izquierda, podrían ser jalados un poco hacia la
izquierda, eso inducirá lo que llamamos un dipolo.
Ahora tendrás una carga parcial negativa en el
lado izquierdo de este átomo y una carga parcial
positiva del lado derecho, y ya teníamos un dipolo
aleatorio en el lado izquierdo, y eso ha inducido
un dipolo en el lado derecho. Un dipolo es cuando
tenemos la separación de cargas, donde las cargas
positivas y las cargas negativas están en dos
partes diferentes de una molécula o un átomo o
realmente cualquier cosa. Pero en este caso, de
repente estos dos personajes se sentirán atraídos
el uno por el otro, los átomos se atraerán entre
sí y esta atracción que sucede debido a dipolos
inducidos es exactamente de lo que tratan las
fuerzas de dispersión de London. En realidad
podemos llamar a las fuerzas de dispersión de
London fuerzas dipolo inducido dipolo inducido,
se sienten atraídos el uno por el otro porque lo
que puede comenzar como un desequilibrio temporal
de electrones induce un dipolo en el otro átomo o
la otra molécula y en seguida se atraen. Así que
la siguiente pregunta que podríamos hacer es: ¿qué
tan fuertes pueden llegar a ser estas fuerzas?
Todo se trata de la noción de polarizabilidad.
¿Qué tan fácil es polarizar un átomo o molécula?
En general, entre más electrones tengamos,
entre más grande sea la nube de electrones
que generalmente se asocia con la masa molar,
mayor será la polarizabilidad porque habrá más
electrones. Si este fuera un átomo de helio que
tiene una nube de electrones relativamente
pequeña, no podríamos tener un desequilibrio
significativo, a lo sumo podríamos tener 2
electrones en un lado, lo que causaría algún
desequilibrio. Pero, por otro lado, imaginemos
1 átomo mucho más grande o una molécula mucho
más grande. Podríamos tener desequilibrios mucho
más significativos. Tres, 4, 5, 50 electrones,
y eso crearía un dipolo temporal más fuerte
que luego induciría un dipolo más fuerte en
los vecinos, eso podría causar un efecto dominó
en toda la muestra de esta molécula. Por ejemplo,
si tuviéramos que comparar algunos gases nobles
entre sí -podemos ver los gases nobles del lado
derecho-, si comparamos las fuerzas de dispersión
de London entre digamos helio y argón, ¿en cuál
crees que serían mayores las fuerzas de dispersión
de London? ¿En una gran cantidad de átomos de
helio juntos o en una gran cantidad de átomos de
argón juntos? Bueno, los átomos de argón tienen
una nube de electrones más grande, así que tienen
mayor polarizabilidad, y van a tener fuerzas de
dispersión de London más grandes. Y podemos ver
esto en sus puntos de ebullición. Por ejemplo,
el punto de ebullición del helio es bastante
bajo, es -268.9°C, mientras que el punto de
ebullición del argón es a baja temperatura según
nuestros estándares, pero es una temperatura mucho
más alta que el punto de ebullición del helio,
está en -185.8°C. Una forma de pensar en esto
es que si tuviéramos -270°C encontraríamos
una muestra de helio en estado líquido,
pero a medida que aumentamos la temperatura, a
medida que superamos los -268.9°C, vamos a ver que
las fuerzas de dispersión de London que mantienen
juntos a estos átomos de helio deslizándose entre
sí en estado líquido van a ser superadas por la
energía debida a la temperatura, y así los átomos
podrán liberarse uno del otro. Y esencialmente el
helio va a hervir y entrar en un estado gaseoso,
el estado en el que la mayoría de nosotros estamos
acostumbrados a ver al helio. Eso no le sucede al
argón sino hasta que está un poco más caliente,
todavía frío para nuestros estándares, y eso es
debido a que se necesita más energía para superar
las fuerzas de dispersión de London en el argón,
porque los átomos de argón tienen nubes de
electrones más grandes, en términos generales,
cuanto más grande es la molécula y debido a que
tiene una nube de electrones más grandes tendrá
una mayor polarizabilidad y mayores fuerzas
de dispersión de London. Pero también es
importante la forma de la molécula. Cuanto
más contacto tienen las moléculas entre sí,
cuanto mayor superficie tengan expuestas entre
ellas, es más probable que puedan inducir estos
dipolos entre ellas. Por ejemplo, el butano
puede venir en dos formas diferentes: en lo que
se conoce como n-butano, que se parece a esto que
voy a escribir, 4 carbonos y 10 hidrógenos: 2, 3,
4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10. A esto se le conoce como
n-butano. Pero hay otra forma de butano conocida
como isobutano y que se vería así: 3 carbonos
en la cadena principal y luego 1 carbono que se
desprende del carbono central, y todos tienen
4 enlaces, los enlaces sobrantes están con los
hidrógenos de modo que se vería así. Esto que
tenemos aquí es isobutano. Ahora, si tuviéramos
una muestra con una gran cantidad de moléculas de
n-butano y una muestra con una gran cantidad de
moléculas de isobutano, ¿cuál muestra crees que
tendría un punto de ebullición más alto? Pausa
el video y piénsalo. Bueno, si tienes una gran
cantidad de moléculas de n-butano, una al lado de
la otra, imagina otra molécula de n-butano justo
aquí, va a tener una mayor superficie expuesta a
sus vecinos butanos porque es una molécula larga
y puede exponer esa superficie a sus vecinos;
mientras que el isobutano de alguna manera es un
poco más compacto, tiene una superficie menor,
no tiene estas grandes cadenas largas. Debido
a que tenemos estas moléculas más largas de
n-butano vamos a tener fuerzas de dispersión
de London mayores. Obviamente tienen el mismo
número de átomos, tienen la misma cantidad de
electrones, por lo que tienen nubes de electrones
de tamaño similar, tienen la misma masa molar,
pero debido a la forma alargada del n-butano
son capaces de acercarse unas a otras e inducir
más estos dipolos. Así que sólo mirando la forma
de n-butano en comparación con la del isobutano
veremos fuerzas de dispersión de London mayores
en el n-butano, de modo que tendrá un punto de
ebullición más alto, va a requerir más energía
para superar las fuerzas de dispersión
de London y entrar en un estado gaseoso.